now the latest on a deadly school
shooting in michigan a lawsuit accuses
officials of ignoring clear warning
signs fifteen-year-old ethan crumbly is
accused of killing four people in the
november 30th attack the lawsuit on
behalf of another student who was shot
at oxford high school includes
disturbing details of the suspect's
alleged behavior elise preston reports
on the lawsuit and crumley's first court
appearance in the case
ethan crumbly remained quiet as his
attorney entered a not guilty plea on 24
counts including murder and terrorism
charges
the michigan teen allegedly opened fire
in a hallway at oxford high school
killing four and wounding seven with a
gun that his parents bought him as an
early christmas present a civil lawsuit
against the oxford community school
district accuses administrators of
putting students in danger by allegedly
downplaying crumbly's actions before the
shooting when he posted countdowns and
threats of bodily harm at one point the
complaint claims that the boy left a
severed bird head in a mason jar
containing a yellow liquid in the boy's
bathroom
the school then emailed students and
parents that there has been no threat to
our building nor our students the
lawsuit also alleges that school
officials knew about these disturbing
drawings including a gun
the school knew that he made statements
such as he can't control his thoughts to
such a degree that the school was on
notice of a dangerous situation had a
duty of care to its other students to
make sure they were safe and simply
failed to act
along with school administrators
crumbly's parents james and jennifer are
also accused of ignoring warning signs
and allowing him access to the gun used
in the shooting they have been charged
with four counts of involuntary
manslaughter at a hearing on friday
prosecutors described texts sent by
ethan to his parents that they say
showed his mental state
ethan crumbly would text his mother
jennifer that he thought there was a
demon a ghost or someone else inside the
home
crumley's parents have both pleaded not
guilty their attorneys maintain that
they were receiving threats and left
their home due to safety concerns
meanwhile an attorney for the school
district tells cbs news some of the
claims in the lawsuit are false and
school officials are cooperating with
prosecutors tony
elise thank you very much